who Shira real Federico scheana right I
didn't okay
in this technique Mike has grabbed both
of my hands behind me it's difficult for
me to use my weapons from here I promise
they're trying to stab at I can be
nearly impossible I wouldn't get my arms
back under my control
so the first thing they do is they sink
back and bring my hands in front now
notice I'm not trying to pull fight into
me no wonder resist me really easy board
so what I do instead like sink myself
back and they do the same push way out
is down and Express Colt you this starts
to raise his elbows I didn't sing
underneath his arm patch on my hip here
and bring it over from the cushy nine
meters one more time to speed Hey hi hi
Mashiro real it or even push dagger